lwe uh thanks for the introduction and
uh
thanks for uh the invitation danielle
and uh
and chris uh so so i'm going to to speak
uh
about uh this algebraic algorithm for
for lwe
so it's going to be a kind of a new
approach
well it's a new unusual approach uh
to assess the security of of lwe
so it's a joint work with martinel
branch carlos sid and george alfred
and actually uh martin bring to us
this lattices uh stuff so we we are
working on mainly on the
fifth is using a grammar basis and it
appears that uh
it can be used also in in this context
so uh very quickly so i'm going to to
consider the
the classical lwe problem
so this is a the definition that uh that
we saw
so just to to fix the notation so
n is going to be the the dimension of uh
of my matrix and
the length so i'm going to uh to
consider the the problem of
actually recovering uh this
uh secret so you can uh uh
see this this problem of learning with
errors as a
decoding a random
linear code with a special type
of distribution and so i will
again simplify the distribution here so
it's a discrete gaussian as
we all know but for me i will only
assume that
each component of the error is a is
small
and so you have a cue the size and this
alpha the parameters
and so we all know that uh this is
secure
so you have the connection to work case
gap is vp
this alpha q is is big enough and so
what
martin uh brings us to us and what uh
what has been interesting for uh uh for
me and john charles
is is the formulation of of the problem
in terms of uh
algebraic equation due to uh arora and
gay
and so it's uh decoding a linear
uh decoding a linear code so it's
solving a
system of linear equation with noise and
so the idea of
aurora and gay was to uh generate from
this
a set of algebraic
equations without noise but no more
linear and what is very nice with this
a result of aurora and gay
is that uh well it gives you a a very
simple
algorithm which is exponential in oh
sorry
so there is it's in the square of a
alpha q
and it terms to be a sub-exponential
if the parameters is a slightly less
to what the security reduction
so uh in some sense it's a a bit uh
frustrating for a
arrage because they were very close to
have a
super exponential algorithm for solving
a gap svp
but on the other hand from the point of
view of the designer
it's very satisfying because
you you regev derived this
uh condition uh on the security
and it was uh uh discovered in a
different way
that actually you require require this
condition
on uh on the distribution
so today what i will
consider is a simple version of
of this problem i'm going to talk
where the er is uh is very small
and so uniform uh in an interval
so i'm going to consider uh what is
called the binary error
lwe by daniele and uh
and and increase and so in this context
so it's the same problem decoding but
there are
here each component of the error is
going to be
0 or 1.
so uh
like for uh lwe uh so you can prove
the the hardness of uh of this uh
variant so you have a connection to a
hard lattice
problem but here's a security
parameter what gives you the security
is not this size of the error
it's going to be a the number of
samples which will
give you the security and
applying this regular algorithm
you can prove that you you can solve
this problem in polynomial time
if you have a n square uh
sample okay and here
well this is uh the limit for
the security okay
so uh so far so good
so for me it's uh it's very nice so it's
a
type of typical thing that we use to do
with uh
with john charles so we reduce
a given problem or the security of a
cryptosystem
to the solving of a non-linear system of
equation and after we try uh
to solve it what is going to be a bit
different here
from what we are doing in in general is
that
in in this context we will try to not
break given parameters
because actually we have no parameters
we will try to uh derive
actually a bond on
the complexity so what we are going to
uh what we will we will do this
by uh using grammar basis
and so the we'll use the modeling
of our again i'm going to show you it's
very easy
and so the idea of a regi is to do a
linearization okay
so for binary lwe
you have a url on degree 2
so you have a product of this form and
so for each variable
you associate a new one so you get a
system of
a linear equation and so if you have
enough
linear equation so n square then you can
solve
the system well of course
you can perform gaussian elimination if
the equations that you are going to
generate
are linearly independent and really the
uh
the very nice the strong point of the
paper of our regi
is to show that if you generate
sufficiently many
a linear equation you do the
linearization
then you will actually be able to solve
the problem
in this way so the rank of the system is
going to be
sufficiently big so you get really a a
a proof of the algorithm
so in the context of a
binary lwe you can do well
this linearization but you have
this number of samples so the question
that we we try to address
with this approach is how much the
security is going to
decrease or to increase how it will
change
in function of this
upper bound for which you have your
polynomial time algorithm
and and the security uh bonds the
security limit
given in the paper and so if you have
less than this number of samples that
this number of equations
then you cannot do linearization and so
you have to uh
to compute a grammar basis
ok so
i will give you some some
few elements on the complexity of
computing
a grammar basis
just know because i guess you are maybe
not
very familiar well i assume that i will
introduce
quickly uh grammar basis and and the
complexity
so you have a system of a polynomial
equation nonlinear
and so your goal is to find the
variety associated to to this so you
want to find the
common zero of the polynomial equation
so in one way when you have a lot of
equation you you do a
linearization and in general
you can compute a grammar basis
so grammar basis will be a so the track
again
will
is going to be a
a special generator set of your
polynomial
ideal which will allow you to compute
the set of solutions so once you have a
granular basis
then you can compute the variety
associated to a to your ideal so we have
a
algorithm for for doing this so it
starts with a
brno berger and so
now the modern view of computing grammar
basis is to uh
to do a linear algebra and so it's
this view is important to uh to uh
to bond well to compute it efficiently
but also to uh to give some bond on the
complexity
so the important uh object to consider
when you compute a grammar basis
with linear algebra is this
a macro matrix okay
so what you are going to do
is to uh so f i are the generator of
your audio
and you will consider a multiple
of your polynomials so here i multiply
each polynomial by by your term
this is going to give me a polynomial of
degree
d okay
for some d and so i i put the
coefficient
of this polynomial uh in a matrix
okay so
the columns are the monomials of degree
smaller than d with d is a bound and
the rho are the multiple of
of my polynomial and so
we know that
if you perform a row echelon form
on this matrix for d big enough
then you can compute a grammar basis
so it allows you to give a rough bound
on the cost of computing a grammar basis
it's going to be the cost of performing
the
linear algebra on
a matrix which is sufficiently big
so the cost of computing the grammar
basis is going to be exponential
in this degree of regularity
so in this talk i assume that the
variety
and the ideal that i'm considering are
zero dimensional so i have
a finite number of solutions
so you have this simple expression for
for the complexity and now the question
is what is how big
is this uh degree of regularity
well in general actually it's uh it's
difficult to
to know what is the degree of of
regularity
and so to compute the degree of figurity
for a given system there is no more
the solution is to compute
the grammar basis in general but
we have a specific family
so if you do some some assumption on on
on the system that that you consider for
which
we can compute explicitly this degree of
regularity
so this uh polynomial
this special family are called the
semi regular sequences
so assuming that the polynomial are
semi-regular
then you can compute explicitly
what is the degree of figurity to do
this
you can see there are this power series
which is actually the generating series
of the wrong defect of your
macro matrix so the coefficient
will encode the rank
with the wrong defect so
the number of columns minus the number
of
linearly independent rows
and from this power series so you can
expand it
you can read the coefficient of
regularity
the degree of regularity it's the index
of the first
coefficient which is 0 or smaller than
0.
so this is a small example and so you
can see here that the degree of
regularity
is uh far
okay and so this semiregular
sequences so you can
see the conditions that that we impose
it's in some sense the uh
generic behavior of the wrong defect
of the machole matrix so for this family
we know uh explicitly
what is the wrong defect of the macular
matrix that you are considering
and so we know
all what we need to uh compute
the complexity of grammar basis
okay so
this is the reference yeah do you
actually need
to computer this number don't isn't it
enough to have an upper bound
good uh yeah it's enough to have an
upper bound but for the moment i don't
say exactly
or i can get an upper bound so this is
going to be my next slide
for zermatt i'm saying that for this
family with this condition
then we know what is the behavior of
the wrong defect of the maculae matrix
and so i want to point here
a difficult point with this semiregular
sequences is that
actually we don't know if a such
sequence
exists so a famous conjecture
which is known as froeberg conjecture is
yes this semi-regular sequences
exist so this is a kind of
frustrating because
this gave you more or less what is the
typical behavior
for the complexity semiregular sequence
for computing a grammar basis
if you sample randomly your equation
for sure if you compute the grammar
basis it's going to be
the albert series is going to be exactly
this one the issue is that
up to now it's well it's difficult to
find
for any parameters an explicit family
which have this uber series
okay and so actually yeah you you can
here you have the series so you can put
you can put special parameters and get
the uh the degree of regularity and so
the complexity
but what is more useful for what i'm
going to present is to have bound
on the degree of of regularity and so
for
uh semi-regular sequences we have a
a bunch of uh approximation on on the
degree of
regularity and for instance
for this type of system
we know that the degree of regularity is
a constant
times n and so you can see here that in
function of the
ratio this constant
uh decrease so this is one example of uh
of behavior for the degree of regularity
and actually the
the global picture for a equation of
degree 2 is a is as follow so this is
the linearization bond okay
so you know that if you have a system of
quadratic equation
then if you have this number of a sample
number of equations
then without probability you you can
solve
in polynomial time actually if you
so this is the linearization if you
compute a grammar basis with a
slightly less equation we know that it's
a polynomial time
if you have this number of a sample and
so we know that
if m is o of n it's exponential and if
it is a software of
n is a sub exponential
so for semi-regular system of equation
we have kind of the exact behavior
on the complexity
and what i would like to point out
is that well in practice you have a if
you sample randomly these equations and
then you have this
and for a zero dimensional system you
have
not the doubly exponential behavior
which maybe you are afraid
when you are the word of a grammar basis
okay so how we can apply
uh this type of things to uh
to binary uh
lwe once we will have the system
you will see it's a pretty uh obvious
but for the moment we have no system but
it's very easy so the
approach of our can be summarized
in one slide so now i'm coming back
i'm coming back to uh uh to my problem
to binary error elderly to your problem
so i want to uh to solve it using a our
gay equation so i know that i have this
equality
okay and so each error is 0
1 and it's i take
this polynomial which vanish in 0 1
and i write
this set of equations
so i just evaluate alpha inform
with unknown as a coefficient of the
secret
which give me a set of m quadratic
equation
in n variables over
a fq ok
and so once we have this
then we can derive bond
on the complexity of solving this setter
of equation but to derive
this bond on the complexity
i will assume that the system that i'm
generating here
is semi-regular okay so this is my
assumption
and so assuming this is the assumption
false or you just don't know that it's
true
i don't know i i will talk about
the assumption just after so if you plug
if you assume that you have
this semi-regularity condition then you
can derive
for various parameters
on the number of how the complexity is
going to change
so under this assumption it's a
pretty straightforward so you get
a complexity with respect
to this approach so if it is a
slightly bigger than a ofn
endoglogan then it is sub-exponential
but it remains exponential
for 2n and for what what was advised
uh in the security which remain
exponential
this approach but after it's it
decreases with the number of
uh of sample okay
and so of course you uh you are
all saying uh well what about this uh
this assumption so this is
uh the question so to to uh uh
we need to know if it is reasonable to
assume that
the system that i'm generating are uh
are semi-regular
so one way to uh to do this is to uh
to do experiments
for n as big as as you can
and so we so we perform
experiments for a different type of
parameters
and so it seems to work
means that the maximum degree reached
during the computation
is exactly the degree which is predicted
by the assumption
of course here i am not attacking
a given parameters so
from the slides that you saw before it's
exponential for the parameters
for the type of parameters used with the
security proof
so uh you are not going to to solve it
in practice but i derive uh
is a asymptotics and so i i want to be
uh well
i would like to be sure that the bonds
that i'm giving
are working for and big enough
so we uh we
try to investigate this this assumption
so first
this is a difficult question
so if we can solve it it goes beyond
beyond this uh this application on the
binary error lwe so this is something
which is a really central when you are
doing a grammar basis computation
we are always using this type of
assumption when we want to
derive a complexity bond
this genericity
so here i'm actually
considering something slightly different
so i'm i'm trying to prove
the assumption not for a random system
of equation
but for something which has some
structure
so the equations that i'm considering
are power of
linear forms so it's not something
completely random but
it appears that uh this type of uh
of system of equation has been
investigated by
by the author of the the conjecture and
he also believes that
this system of equation are indeed
semi-regular and actually prove it
in some restricted cases
so when the number of sample m is equal
to
2n plus 1. so we try to go
and prove the assumption in some
restricted cases so i will finish
uh with this to show you uh
what what is the difficulty uh here
so let's say we take the uh the simple
case
so we want to prove the assumption that
the smallest degree so we want to prove
that the equation are
are linearly independent okay and so i'm
taking
the maximum number of equations smaller
than
the bond which is given by by a regi
and so i want to prove that
this equation are uh linearly uh
independent
so the tool that i'm going to use is a
is strong zippo
so what i want to prove is that uh
so it's a wrong condition so uh
i have a determinant so i want to prove
that
a determinant is nonzero with a good
probability
so it's a wrong condition so so you have
the polynomial but the issue
is to find one particular example
for which your polynomial is
is non-zero okay and so this is
the tricky point of proving this
assumption
is that you have to find
a specific family for which you can
prove
that if you take this matrix j
then it is indeed of the rank when you
generate the system
uh that that you expect so we can do it
in some particular cases
but in general it's a it's a complete
mess
and so i i think that we have not
exactly the good tool to address
this question so i will
come to my conclusion here so i'm not
too much sure it's okay
so well paper describing
this approach so we can derive
bound also for
lwb but you have also to to assume some
genericity conditions
okay and uh so i
i will finish with some uh some open
question and uh
and for you so i'm i'm kind of looking
for a
comments and uh about this because what
we did
so the modeling is very naive
and so uh we know that if you
want to get something uh uh to go
beyond this we need to go a
bit deeper in in the problem
so as danielle mentioned so
you need to know more lattices so uh
for us we need to uh uh to we need some
help
to uh to have some additional properties
that we can use for the modelling to go
a bit further
and so the the other open question is a
is to prove
uh this assumption so i think it's uh
it's uh of independent uh
interest so it's a classical issue in a
schwarzepaul lemma you want to prove
that something is
is non-zero but here we want to
construct
family of matrices which have
a specific rank so for the moment
we are trying to take a very simple uh
example of matrix see what is the macro
layer
system macromatrix corresponding and
trying to prove
this by end so it's clear that uh
we are going to be able to prove maybe
in
restricted cases but uh
it's not probably not possible to uh to
prove the full assumption
uh in this way
uh uh well i will finish uh by
mentioning
a paper of pierre allen fook and paul
kirchner
and he will give a i think he will give
a presentation tomorrow
and uh never better
result on the binary error lwe
and more generally on lwe
that's all
uh so for for the binary lwe uh
you take this quadratic polynomial of
these linear forms
so you get quadratic polynomial
uh if your noise is coming from a larger
set of size b then you get a degree b
so how do the run times and the number
of samples
roughly behave as b increases
so that's a good question so i was
giving the same talk
three weeks ago and vadim asked me the
same question
and so the the technical issue
is that uh
to derive this type of uh of results
so for uh each family of
n on each degree so you have to do a
an analysis on the series so you have to
do
so you have analytic tools and so you
have to uh it's not automatic
and so if you say well i want uh
instead of quadratic i want a degree a a
three
then i have uh we have to do all all the
analysis again
so it's to go to give you precisely uh
what is the behavior it's difficult but
the global trend
i can so
if it is degree d then
i can linearize with the end of d
so i'm going to be a polynomial so i
replace
here with slightly smaller number of
samples so
d minus one
so here i will still be uh
exponential okay so i
the constant will change and
uh if what is surprising is if you have
a
m log n so you still sub exponential
let's say for d equal three so this i
know for d equals three
d equals four for any d so if d is not a
constant it's
the techniques are different
yeah so i don't know a lot about this
area so this
very well could be a stupid question but
it seems like some of the tools you're
using here are some of the same tools
that are used to build and break
like specifically like multivariate
quadratic based
cryptosystems exactly so do you think
that
we could is there a way to prove some
kind of connection between
those hardness assumptions in lwe i mean
that
they're not it's not like obvious that
there is a connection but
do you think that a connection could
exist so it's not a
thank you a lot for the question because
i skipped this point
so i was mentioning at some point that
so this type of of tools is used to uh
to attack a various type of scheme
so typically a multivariate and a
code based scheme but in in general
when uh when we are on this problem
then we have not this behavior
so assuming that the system is to be
regular
it's kind of a worst case assumption
so most of the time if the system
that we have behave like this then we
give up
so it means that that it's secure and so
the difference
here is that the degree that you are
going to have
is much smaller so typically in a if you
have system
uh which are coming from a chiffee or
multivariate scheme
then you know that the degree of
regularity is going to be constant
uh uh when you increase the parameters
and so i think the the fundamental
difference
here is that
in this case you have no proof of
security
okay so you have the scheme and it's a
possible that you have some middle
structure sorry
and in this case of of lwe
when you attack the scheme when you try
to uh to break
lwe then you have to uh to solve a
circle we and uh with no structure at
all
so it's it's random matrix so you have
to go directly with a difficult
uh problem so in these cases uh
we have a a a different type of problem
different type of structure that uh that
we can
exploit but well coming back back to the
uh
talk of this morning here for compact
michaelis
version what we use for coding and
so coding schema and what i show here
it's
very close and here what what we
we have been able to use is that uh the
matrix which are constructing in
immaculate generator matrix
they are a block structure
and each block is let's say cyclic or
diadic as has some kind of
structure and so in this case uh
we we can we can exploit and so if the
system has some symmetries in general
then we we have a specific bond
in function of the symmetries so we have
degree of regularity which
which can be uh much smaller
all right uh let's take them